good afternoon to everybody welcome to
this session where we have Spotify
sharing with us how they use Google
cloud platform in their back-end
infrastructure we have Nelson our app a
software engineer from Spotify here so
this talk would be in English I am
Giovanni galore oh I am a customer
engineer in Google cloud Italian team
here's the agenda we will start with
Nelson doing an overview on Spotify and
on the event delivery system then I will
provide an overview of Google cloud
platform and its most important feature
then Nelson will go on we go through the
description the architecture of the
various components of their event
delivery system and I will help him in
describing the Google services that are
involved hello it's a pleasure to me for
me to be here
so before jumping in the our system I
would like to do an introduction of what
is Spotify I hope some of you know what
Spotify you're ready yeah okay most of
you yeah we are music streaming system
and at the beginning our key feature was
this huge catalog and the the feeling
the all this catalog is on your device
so streaming this music really fast was
one of our key features and yeah it was
great though now this became a commodity
so people yet this is reputation how
else it would be so to be on top of the
game we need to
versus the data that we have collected
about our users and so we are collecting
this data creating new features and
making available to our users if you are
user and fortified this something we
released a few weeks back is that we
show you what you have been listening in
the previous summer so you can't
remember yet this is what's a catchy
song that was playing at that time also
this is the liver based on data we
create a personalized playlist for each
user also discovery quickly this is we
present a playlists of songs that we
think you would like but you have had
not been listened to so this is a great
way to discover new music so all this
happens is because we have the data
being generated on the clients go to our
event delivery system and then from
there we do several stuff like building
these recommendations in the engines
also very important we need to pay our
Creator sound the music creators labels
artisan from sound writers so we do a
bit testing to understand how our users
use our products and so on and so on so
all I will say our evidence is in the
start of this your day so basically what
we do is we collect all this data and
make it available in the digital storage
so our downstream user could build data
pipelines that will take this data and
do crunching and investing these new
features something I have to say we are
140 million monthly users we are
consuming a 1.5 millions of events per
second
this is about city terabyte of data
okay so let's provide an introduction
about Google cloud platform as you
probably heard this morning Google has
some or many probably products that are
actually used by more than 1 billion of
users and anybody of us has the
visibility of the level of scalability
of performance and and availability of
these products what Google want to do
with Google cloud platforms is to let
their enterprise customers use the same
platform the same technology services
the same hardware network software stack
that you heard about this morning that
Google itself used to run his products
Google wants to let this platform be
available to their enterprise customers
so they can run their products on on on
this platform during the years Google
developed the series of technologies to
run its products technologies that
became technical papers white papers
starting from Google file system and
then to MapReduce in 2004 that then
became the Hadoop open source project
and Dremel and board for example that
became cuber natives or tensorflow and
in Google cloud platform you find the
same technologies productized as a
service for customer that you see here
divided in compute services database
services storage services machine
learning and Big Data one team that
in Google in Google cloud platform is
always has been trying to do at the
maximum accident is to provide several s
components is to provide components
where users as only to bring their code
and their data or then they're called or
their data and all the infrastructure
provisioning and management is done by
Google by the automation that's in in
the platform this started in 2008 with
App Engine it's the platform as a
service where who deploys application
can deploy application directly on the
path on the platform with the
development tools or code deployment
tools and then continued with the
services like cloud storage bigquery and
cloud pub/sub that are used by Spotify
too and that will be discussed in this
session but we know also that in some
transitional period in cloud adoption
and to address some specific needs
related to specific customization the
traditional virtual machines
infrastructure as a service sometimes
are the best option so this will be part
of this discussion too and this is an
area where Google is continuing to
innovate Thank You Ronnie so I will be
first a designer review this is our
platform in very high level we collect
events from the clients and we produce
those events into pop shop
this helped us to collect data from all
our data centers we use we still have
comprend data centers and also Google
ones so but any any how we collect all
this data around the world
we use the amazing Google Network and
then we pull that data from our
consumers and then make it available in
Google Cloud storage as a set of files
and we have a specific format I will
talk about this later and yes because we
want these event delivery system to be a
cell service we have an automation
deployment that our developers just
configure what event they want to send
and we are able to deploy it
infrastructure using Google Cloud API so
all we don't have to be blocking anybody
they just configure and are able to
deliver thank you in the in the design
that in the design that Nelson show
there are three hexagons free Google
cloud platform components one of these
is pub/sub pub/sub is a messaging
service that completely managed
messaging service that provide a
synchronous messaging between
independent applications it basically
implements publisher subscriber
architecture where there is a publishing
application submitting a message into a
topic and a subscribing application that
has subscribed to a topic of interest
and retrieve the message when it when it
comes online pub/sub can act as a buffer
between application because his message
store can hold the messages until the
subscribing application is ready to
receive the message and it has dedicated
capacity in on Google cloud platform
region it has been tested to have
sub-second timing in notification and in
message delivery even when has been
tested at 1 million events per second
and it used HTTP so the publishing
application can be any application
supporting HTTP GET request subscribing
application can act in two ways can in a
pool way it has to support HTTP GET
request and in a push mode where pub/sub
push messages directly to the
application the subscribing application
has to expose webbook supporting HTTP
POST request another component is Google
Cloud storage is an object storage where
data stored and our server does binary
object it's support an unlimited number
of binary objects with a maximum size of
5 terabyte and it it can be used for
example to serve a web content because
it's access that it's accessible with
the HTTP protocol with standard web
protocol it can be used to us to to
store data related to archival or
disaster recovery or to provide to users
access to download access to big files
Google uses this service Google Cloud
Storage as a back-end storage for media
files in Google Photos for attachment in
Gmail and for all the all the documents
in Drive it provides replication and I
availability so customer doesn't have to
manage high availability it is
accessible as I said with HTTP we XML
API JSON API and with the Google cloud
platform console itself or Jess util
common line it provides different
storage classes this different Islay SLA
multi-regional and regional are for data
access very frequently material in
multi-regional you have data replicated
between Curie
in the same macro area for example in
Europe in US or in Asia original you
have data replicated only inside one
region in near line is for data that is
accessed said less than one time amount
and cold line is for data our archival
storage mainly for data that is access
at less than once a year then we have
bigquery bigquery is basically a
completely managed service that provides
the users the ability to perform queries
analytics reports on huge data set with
a with a very fast performance it our
equivalent of an enterprise data
warehouse with the difference that uses
only to load data and perform the
queries users doesn't have to allocate
capacity provision server user doesn't
have the notion of capacity neither
because capacity is allocated
dynamically on demand when user perform
the query based on D on the amount of
data on on which the query are
performant and its support access via
JDBC ODBC via bigquery API common line
and an HTTP UI and then back to the
Spotify architecture thank you so yet
the first diagram was very high level
this is a level deeper this is still the
three big areas so we will start with
the producing side so as I told you
before we produce more than 1.5 million
of them per second
this is like a brush because there is a
daily pattern we have high tide and low
tide so
and this is how it looks we have the our
clients and advance they eventually will
reach microservice in our data centers
so each of these micro service will
write the event as a lock line as a
syslog look like a tax so on those holes
we have the deployed half-demon and we
call it the file tailor because what it
does is just add that we tells the lock
line and make sure that that event have
been pushed to separately to our event
River sister it reads line by line don't
have if very dumb doesn't have much
logic send it to our nest component 7
service and then if you get 200 is to
say yes it was persisted sucessfully in
also this lock line could be like the
start rate so it will be will receive an
invalid code so okay I don't need to
fret right but if it's not if it's not
that 200 this is not invalid call so he
will free try to make sure the data have
input and we don't lose any data this is
the where the business log is happening
here we parse the text line we have a
schema definition so make sure that this
match one of our events we also convert
it to a bro because we will push a bro
binary from this point until the end we
also check this event against a white
list because it's easier for us they
were changing in the what is while is to
prevent publishing some labelled then
rolling out change to our clients to
stop producing relevant so spending is
good but wait is not does this our
motors and Spotify so if we don't
to send that event we will just say no
invalid don't preach right so if
everything is okay then we push this
event to a Google pops up and we use one
topic per event type so this provides
very good isolation we have not all the
bands are the same and we have metrics
related to the specific event type so we
like it this way
then on the consumer side we have all
those events arriving in pub subtopics
and we create subscriptions and then we
pulled that data using ETL processes I
will plan further worried how this ETL
looks like but then once we pulled the
data we do some totient add to that data
for support removing duplicate our
clients recent events and also being a
distributed architecture could have
duplicates all the way so this is a
component they handle that and then make
it available in Google Cloud storage and
we use a very specific format this is
how it looks we use a cloud storage has
something called buckets let's say like
like a drive a place where I can store
objects or files but inside this bucket
we have we have a semantic pocket of
event sorry
date and time so we say ok this specific
date this is a specific hour we will
store in that folder
or the data have have been happening for
this epic event so once we think we are
consuming all the data we say ok we mark
this hour as complete so this is how
looks in time yeah we are making these
data as a complete
until that point is when our downstream
user will start to run and consume this
data we don't want to say okay then
consume downstream dependencies please
start your crunching time and then later
modify that data set because then we
will need to retrigger our dependencies
downstream dependencies and then they
will need to retriever their
dependencies too so we take care of not
doing that we treat once we mark a
folder as complete
we don't allow to modify that data
but because everything could happen
let's say we have an hour they we
already mark as complete but so only
late date arrive for that hour this will
happen because we use heuristic to
determine when it's time to close it
their work so not know the risk is not
always 100% fine every time so what we
do is that yet this is already closed
but then we will move these few events
they arrive late to the net outward is
still open so our Dom tree user are
aware of these so that they will know
that if for example this our tree
potentially could contain events from
our top or something so so in the in
this consumer side Nelson will introduce
other components that are part of Google
cloud platform one of these components
is cloud sequel cloud sequel is
basically completely managed the
database of service offering that
provide application level access to my
sequel DB or Postgres DB users have to
configure only
the compute capacity needed the storage
capacity needed if they want replication
and the Google cloud platform automation
managed operating system patching
backups and replication between zones it
exposed a basic connection string that
you can use the user can use in in their
application another another component
that is used in the consumer part of the
Spotify when delivery system is cloud
data prod Cloud Data proc is a managed
service again that provide Hadoop and
spark jobs a Dupin spark cluster is it
automates the deployment of the cluster
the management of the cluster and spark
and Hadoop jobs always require a large
amount of data a large number of nodes
so in this case the the elasticity and
scalability of cloud can help because
for example you can pay the resource
only when you have a job to run and then
you can shut down the nodes after the
job has run you can have the resources
immediately available and you don't have
to wait for a server to be acquired the
cobbler install a dance-off to be being
configured and you can scale at the
maximum extent and number of nodes so
the fact that you are not allocating
capacity but you are using capacity only
when you need to run the job enables you
to run it at the maximum number of nodes
and finish the job sooner and having the
business result quicker and then let's
go to the rest of the architecture yeah
ok so this is a assuming of what our ETL
looks like we decided to build our ETL
as 3 micro services consumer
completionists and the duper
so the consumers is very dumb process
he pulls data from pops up and then it
will write that data I mean he pulled a
batch of events I will write this
purchase of a small file in the one
intermedia Google Cloud storage so we
put it there and then we notify this
other component called completions I
would fling more what it does and when
the completion say ok yes I I persist
your notification that you have a new
file with data then is when the consumer
had knowledge observed this yes I have
consumed sucessfully dispatch of event
it something happen in this and for some
reason we are not able or the
completions didn't return we have some
problems right into storage we know that
because we do not know at knowledge
those events those events are last year
still safe store in the pub so so by
doing this we are making sure that we
are safely moving the data from pub/sub
and make it available as files in all
clouds this intermediate bucket in
Google Cloud storage so this completion
is is the the name is because this is
the component that decides when the noir
is complete so for doing that I use a
cloud sequel as a database so when I
release receive a notification the other
consumer has produced this file for this
event at this date an hour so it will
store that in a database and this is
worth the risk of completing the hour
Chris a sister so here we use when was
the last time that consumer wrote a file
how the Battle of in the Google pub/sub
looks like we are able to get a matrix
said where is the time some of the
oldest events that haven't been
so there we know yes we still have data
on Google storage so we cannot close
this out at this moment so once all
these conditions are met yet the
completion is that decide to close an
hour and then if the for example in the
producer side this is what could happen
suddenly we need to append a few events
for all the hours so consumer will put
it and then the completion we say ok no
sorry we already closed this hour I
would move it to the next then the last
component is the duper the name is
because here when we do that allocation
this is a MapReduce job the runs on data
prep we have a schedule service stop and
serve all the states that when it's time
to run is we say please run this the
duplication job every hour so when it's
time to run it will trigger this job
then the duper first ask the completion
is this our complete if it is it will
return a list of files from the
intermediate storage so this is a list
of file I need to read and the duplicate
so the after this in its initiation the
the duper yoga teachers I must reduce
that do the runs for the application we
this is written in Apache crunch and we
spawn theta pro cluster just to run that
job and when we finish with redundant
that data per cluster and yes we make it
available on Google Cloud storage so I
have plain how we produce how we consume
now the missing pair is how this get
configured as I told you before we don't
want to be a team that brought other
developers on Spotify so we need to
manage these 250 event types and these
present two challenges one is that Jesse
Stone
is a lot of event types that we need to
make it in a way they be configurable
and the other is the event times are not
the same we have for example one Levin
type is every time the user has played a
song but we have other event I for
example feature we are developing that
we only feel with the tester are using
that feature so we go from a hundreds of
event per second to only a few events
per minute so we need a way to scale the
consume the consumption to know yes for
this event type we need to pull the lot
but for this other set with only few
parameters is enough so to address this
scale needs what are the services on the
capabilities that are in Google cloud
platform you can scale instances in a
vertical way so you can add more
capacity to a single instance you can do
that on Google cloud platform with the
advantage that you have custom VM types
so you can provide to an instance
exactly the amount of CPU core and the
amount of RAM that you need no less no
more you don't have to be bound to fix
it VM sizes where there is a predefined
ratio between number of core and
gigabyte of RAM and this is this is very
helpful and during the usage your
resource usage is monitored and you get
from Google apart from console
suggestion for example if you are not
currently using efficiently or your
capacity you have suggestion to downsize
your resistance and you have estimate of
the billing saving that you can do as on
the other side if you are reaching the
peak of the capacity you provided
you have suggestion to increase the
capacity assign it to your VMs but
vertical scalability is often not enough
for example because you reach a limit
and your you are enabled to scale to
provide to serve all this number of
users this number of events so if you
want to overcome this limit you have to
use horizontal scaling you have to add
instances to multiply the resources
assign it to your service you do this in
Google cloud platform with manage
instance group where a set of instance
is managed as a single entity they are
completely equal among them so their
configuration is based on an instance
template where you decide what is the
base image on which the instances had to
be based on what is the configuration
what is the network configuration the
startup script etc then you deploy these
instances you can have Regional Manager
distance group where you deploy the
instances across different zones in the
same region and you have a load balancer
spread in traffic between them so you
have full tolerance you have high
availability if one or more instance or
a complete zone goes down and you have
Auto scale tool so you can configure
auto scaling so instances can be added
to your manage instance group if your
load increase and can be removed if your
load decrease you can do that base it on
different matrix for example CPU usage
or number of requests hitting your
service or a custom a custom metric tool
you can do running a parade if you need
to operate your code you can update your
instance template and trigger a control
add update that will update your service
in a progressive way not disrupting your
services you use
continue to work and you can configure
how to Ealing so when your instance
doesn't respond to an elf check that you
configure it your instance has will be
killed and will be replaced
okay so going back to the program in
automation
so we have our which events are defining
system defining we have a distributed
configured service and we use these
first of the event service to populate
the wine list so we are able to forget
those who are not in this whiteness and
we have a deployment service that talks
to Google cloud engine and then every
ETL is a managed group GC manager group
with an auto scalar policy of CPU usage
so the our consumer this is the one we
treat this way is very simple because we
don't need to handle how big or how
small is event we just say ok we are
pulling and more they're more backlog
listen rule in pops up the more CPU
usage will consume this consumer and
then ultra scale policy will decide oh
looks like we need more VMs because the
threshold is higher than the one we set
so we have autoscaler deploy more VM so
we are pulling more data from but
support across many VMs and we decide to
use all small VM so we don't waste too
much resources so those few events are
only a few events per minute so we have
a Morbihan but we have with the
autoscaler - yes for those that we need
more resource or please respond more
machines or more beams
okay yeah I think we are done I don't
know if there is time for questions so
we have four minutes right if there are
questions yeah anyways we will be
outside here if you want to personally
no question probably Oh a question
hi why are you processing the message
before pushing them to PAVA sub and why
are not processing them after so after
retrieving them from pub sub you say why
we don't push from clients to pops up
yeah something or I mean done by
interface between the two because here
you're doing some applying some logic
that could be time-consuming
yeah there are two
answer for that one is legacy the three
answer is that before we use a system
based on Kafka and I can't talk about
some scars that I have because that's
that system so we decide to replace
build the system keeping the same API
and the beginning that idea right now we
are working on the library to push to
publish directly from here to sort from
here we still want to Darrin service we
want still some controls we don't want
to push credential to our our micro
services but we will skip these two
steps and who is directly okay
okay thank you we are done thank you
[Applause]